the central idea of classical European
social theory is the idea that society
is made and imagined the structures of
social life are our creation Vico said
we can understand society because we
made it so we shouldn't think of these
structures in the way in which we think
of the atomic structure of a natural
object they are artifacts our artifacts
rather than natural phenomena this was
the central idea of the tradition of
classical European social theory the
most consummate example of which is the
social theory of Karl Marx but this idea
when taken to the hilt would lead us to
the notion that all the arrangements of
society are a kind of frozen politics so
these structures arise to the extent
that conflict practical and visionary
conflict over the terms of social life
is interrupted or contained or to change
the metaphor it's like a game of musical
chairs the music stops the music being
the conflict and then the chairs on
which we sit are the structures this Reb
Ellucian Aryan site in social theory was
circumscribed by a series of illusions
that compromised its force these are the
illusions of false necessity the first
of these illusions is the idea that
there is in history a closed list of
such structures for example feudalism
capitalism and socialism in Marx the
modes of production there is no such
closed list the second illusion of false
necessity is the illusion of
indivisibility that each of these
structures is an indivisible system
which to be replaced must be replaced
all at once by another system for
example feudalism by capitalism or
capitalism by socialism and this second
illusion the illusion of indivisibility
has an enormous practical consequence
the practical consequence is to mislead
us into the view that there are
basically only two kinds of politics
there is the revolutionary substitution
of one indivisible system by another or
there is the reformist management or
humanization of a system so today for
example you can ask what's the project
of the progressives and the answer is
for the most part they have no project
their project is the humanization of the
project of their conservative
adversaries and they justify this
abdication by appealing to the notion of
revolution a real chains a structural
change would be the substitution of one
system for another it's not in the cards
and if it were it would be too dangerous
so let's make the best of a situation
and humanize the system that we have
especially through compensatory
redistribution by tax and transfer
what the what the illusion of
indivisibility disregards is that change
can be structural and nevertheless
piecemeal fragmentary gradual and
experimental we should not associate
radical change with wholesale change and
gradual change with inconsequential
change the third illusion is the
illusion that there are laws governing
the succession of indivisible systems in
history and if there are laws then
there's no role for the programmatic
imagination for the imagination of
alternatives so think of what happens
today if I propose something that's very
distant from present reality you say
that's interesting but it's utopia if I
propose something close to what exists
you answer that's feasible but it's
trivial and that's everything that is
proposed can be derided as either
utopian or trivial this false dilemma
arises from a misunderstanding of the
nature of the programmatic imagination
it's not about blueprints it's about
succession it's not architecture its
music but the confusion is aggravated by
our inability now to believe in any of
the master narratives of historical
change that we have inherited from the
tradition of classical social theory and
because we cannot rely on these
narratives we fall back on a bastardized
conception of political realism which is
that the proposal is realistic to the
extent that it approaches what already
exists what then is the task the task is
to recover the central revolutionary
insight of classical social theory and
liberate this insight from the illusions
of false necessity and if we were to
take that task
seriously we would then have to contest
the orthodoxies that now prevail across
the whole field of social sciences and
humanities in the positive social
sciences the hard social sciences
economics first among them what we find
are rationalizing tendencies that
explain the established arrangements in
a way that vindicates their necessity
and their authority in the normative
disciplines of political philosophy and
legal theory what we find are humanizing
tendencies pseudo philosophical props to
the ameliorative practices of
compensatory redistribution and of
idealization of the law and in the
humanities what we find is escapism
consciousness embarks on a rollercoaster
of subjective adventurism disconnected
from the transformation or even the
criticism of society these rationalizing
humanizing and escapist tendencies in
fact converge their practitioners
pretend to be enemies but they are in
fact allies in the disarmament of the
transformative imagination what is the
central problem in contemporary social
thought the central problem is the
breaking of the vital link between
insight into the actual and imagination
of the possible imagination of the
adjacent possible of what can happen
next to understand the phenomenon is to
grasp what it can become or in different
words the central problem is the failure
of structural imagination any account of
how these structures are generated of
how they can be disrupted and of how we
can establish out
of structures the project that I
proposed of recovering the central
inside of classical social theory and
freeing it from the illusions of false
necessity is in the service of the
attempt to contest these rationalizing
humanizing and escapist tendencies and
to establish a transformative
imagination at the center of our
understanding of society many who hear
these words may be discouraged they may
think that intellectual political and
even moral projects like those that I
have described can be undertaken only by
geniuses and prophets by visionaries and
rebels and that are beyond the reach of
an ordinary person but part of the
message is that they are not beyond the
reach of ordinary people and that each
of these tasks that I have discussed in
our conversation can be translated into
small practices into small practices
that are within our grasp so for example
the task of rescuing the inside of
social theory of saving it from the
illusions of false necessity and of
defying the established orthodoxies in
the social sciences and humanities need
not take the form of a comprehensive
theory or philosophy it can take the
form of particular critical and
explanatory practices in particular
disciplinary settings and once again in
thought as in politics deep transfer
nations can begin in small initiatives
now I say the same with respect to the
political and moral ideas that I
discussed there two chains requires
neither saintliness nor genius what it
does require is the conviction of the
incomparable value of life
nothing should matter more to us then
the attempt to grasp our life while we
have it and to awaken from this slumber
of routine of compromise and of
prostration so that we may die only once
hope is not the condition or cause of
action hope is the consequence of action
and those who fail in hope should should
act practically or conceptually so that
they may hope
you